So, we've transported you into an MDP,
or
actually we didn't transport
you into anything.
We're giving you the ability to interact
with an MDP, and here's the MDP.
Now, remember I said the MDP,
the environment has states and actions.
Now, the states in this case, are
going to be visualized to you in terms
of this sort of Mondrian looking
picture in the middle of the screen.
>> Mondrian?
I'm going to go with that.
>> Okay.
>> And it's like colors and
squares and things.
And the actions are the numbers
one through six.
And unlike in a regular video game,
you don't know the rules.
You don't really know how things work.
You don't even know what it is you're
trying to do, but what you can do is
start playing and use that experience
to start figuring out how things work.
>> Okay, so it's just like grad school.
>> [LAUGH] Maybe.
All right, so you have to now choose
actions, and I'll enter them into
the MDP and we'll see what happens and
then you can see if you can win or not.
>> Okay.
>> Get my reward.
>> Three.
Three.
>> I did it.
Just nothing changed.
>> Five.
>> I did it.
Nothing changed.
>> Six?
I'm back where I was.
>> That's true.
>> One.
>> Nothing changed.
>> Two.
>> Three.
>> That's a new state.
>> It is a new state.
>> Three.
>> Oh, so I figured something out then.
>> Do you want to tell me what it is?
>> No, because I forgot what I
did [LAUGH] three steps back.
>> Okay.
>> I've decided that three
means move to the right.
>> Okay.
>> And something moves down, but
I can't remember what I said.
I want to say it was two, but
I guess I could try that.
Two.
Yes.
Now I need to figure out
how to go back up again.
One?
>> Nothing happened.
>> Four?
Four?
Four, Five.
>> Nothing happened.
>> Six.
So I think that's
visually very attractive.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, cool.
So I think my actions mostly
moved the orange square around.
And now I just need to know what
[LAUGH] it's trying to accomplish.
How about two, two,
two, two, five.
>> Nothing happened.
>> Six.
>> Four, four, three,
three, three, two,
two, three, one.
Nothing happened.
>> Four.
Four.
>> All right.
So you seem to have at
least gotten the feel for
the idea that there's four directional
actions for the orange square.
>> Yeah.
>> In fact maybe we should actually
notate them just to make it a little bit
easier to hold in your head.
>> Okay.
>> But you do notice that there are some
actions that you haven't quite gotten to
do anything yet.
>> Yeah, and now that I don't
have to remember what they are.
I mean sure two, three, four and
six math exactly as you would expect
them two, two, down, right, up and left.
But I was having a hard time
keeping them in my head.
So let's try six.
Six, two, two,
six, six, four,
four, one.
>> Nothing happened.
>> Three, six, five.
The little yellow circle thing.
>> Or green.
Green is good.
>> Okay,
the green little circle thing shrunk.
Oh, three.
Oh, that's interesting.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Two, two, three,
three, three, four, four.
I should do something now.
One.
>> Success.
>> Yes.
I get it.
I think I even understand
what the game is.
>> Okay, let's show you the game
again and maybe you can explain it.